your employees are not your customers
all right your company is always your
customer
number one because the company balances
the priorities of everyone the
shareholders
the customers and the employees
[Music]
what's going on everyone um i wanted to
i'll probably make a couple of podcasts
um
about my day yesterday but it was our uh
quarterly meet up for our leadership
and uh there was kind of you know
there's a few kind of i don't say
teaching moments but moments where i was
kind of able to transfer some of my
you know more updated beliefs about how
a company should run
um that they were like man i wish we'd
record this like that would have been
such a good podcast and so
um i want to try and do my best and kind
of cover some of those points with you
here so you can almost be like a fly on
the wall
um in some of those meetings and so the
first one
was about the role of hr now um before
all of the entrepreneurs who are
listening to this you know have their
eyes
glaze over this is probably the first
podcast i've ever made about you know hr
and human resources
but i think it's incredibly important
and
it's not just about if you have an hr
department so for many of you might only
have a handful of employees
um or or you're a manager at a company
so if you know
entrepreneurs if you have a management
or series of managers or leaders in the
company i think
for them to understand um what
the role of human resources and and
investing in employees looks like
i think it would be valuable so i'm
going to start with a story of
hr gone wrong um and then
kind of go from there and kind of
dissect it as like a little mini case
study
uh or to the best of my ability and so
um
to expound upon the many lessons and
failures that i have had
uh in running the business um
a few a year or two ago um we had an hr
uh director and
uh they i'll just tell you what happened
so
she had taken upon herself um because
she didn't have enough work
i i know this but she doesn't know this
it was because she didn't have enough
work
and she had over hired she had six
people in her department
six people in hr can you imagine um six
we had a hundred person company like six
people like it's just so many people
uh so she had a lot of people and no one
had any work to do
and so um she took it upon herself to do
a
a salary analysis which is basically a
study of how much everyone in the
company
um you know quote should be getting paid
based on you know the role their
experience what the market's playing and
where they live
right and um this took like 90 days for
her to do this for every single person
in the company and so she used up you
know
a lot of company resources three four
five employees et cetera
for this period of time to do the study
uh and the result of the study was that
she had determined that you know
i don't know 20 or 25 of the company um
was being you know overpaid and then 20
or 25 percent of the company was being
underpaid and then about 50 percent of
the company was being paid
you know appropriately and so the
conclusion that she came to was well
um i'm going to email everyone and just
say uh if you know if
if they were being overpaid uh they were
going to stay there
because you're not going to give people
you know pay cuts
if they're adequately paid they'll stay
where they're at and if someone's being
underpaid
uh we'll email them and say hey you just
got a raise congratulations
right um and so this may have been
the single stupidest thing i have ever
seen someone do
in my entire life um but
that was the decision that was made and
so um this was reported to me at a uh
at eight what do you call it a uh at our
quarterly
and this was actually her accomplishment
for the quarter and i just
i just remember just being so
so bewildered
befuddled dumbfounded um by the fact
that that this person this human being
had thought that this was a
good use of company resources
and so i'm going to break down the many
reasons why this is not a good idea or
this was a terrible
thing and then kind of outline what i
believe
uh the the ideal role of hr is in a
company
so the reason this was terrible uh was
that um
so she literally used company resources
probably a hundred thousand dollars of
payroll resources to create
this solution that then just paid out
more money from the company
um which is just my wallet it's just my
bank account right
and just paid out more money for no
reason
and did it in a way that anybody who got
paid more had no explanation
for why they were getting paid more and
provide no value so she literally wasted
money doing it wasted money for that
point going forward in the company
because after someone gets an email i
can just be like oh by the way
she was wrong sorry about that and then
we're just gonna get keep you back where
you were
um and so i think the whole thing
probably cost me like six hundred
thousand dollars in profit
right like i mean like more than she was
going to get paid for
years right and it just seemed like it's
just a small thing like ah it's just the
company right
and so this is where you know if you're
a manager in a bigger company or you
direct rep
you know if you report directly to the
ceo or the owner
you have to understand this right and so
um
yesterday at our quarterly uh our
current hr director
uh that drake our director's not with us
anymore
uh was bringing up her she was kind of
giving her
uh position on what she believed
her value to the company was and and i
ended up kind of giving a talk about
this in general
and this so this is uh for my current hr
director this is not about our
conversation or anything like that
but this is just in general for everyone
so
i wrote some notes down because i think
it was really important
and so uh one of the things that i hear
a lot is
my role is to make employees happy all
right so i'm going to just hit
eat piece by piece your job
is not to make employees happy as an
owner your job is not to make employees
happy
as a manager your job's not to make
employees happy as an hr director your
job is not to make employees happy
employees job is to make employees happy
human beings are responsible for making
themselves happy there are people in
auschwitz who wrote books about how they
were happy
and there are people in america living
in the top one percent
of earners of the whole world who are
miserable
and depressed all right your job is not
to make people happy
people will choose to be happy based on
their own beliefs about their
circumstances and what
their thoughts are independent from the
actual
things that are happening to them so
first off it is not your responsibility
it is your responsibility to try and
find people who are going to have a
positive inclination who are going to
fit in with the culture
so that we can keep an atmosphere that
does retain and attract
talent which is the next thing i'm going
to get to but your job is not to make
people happy
all right number two uh
one of the things i i heard um is that
employees are my customer
right if you're a manager or an hr
director like well really
you know everyone who works here is my
customer incorrect
that is not who your customer is your
customer is the company
all right and now i'm going to be clear
about this the company has three
stakeholders
you've got shareholders the people who
own the company you've got
uh customers the people who pay the
company and then you've got employees
the people who run the company
all three stakeholders have to be
considered now
the reason this is an important
delineation is that
if you have an hr director who is like
employees first
then you have the type of stupid stupid
decision that i just discussed in the
very beginning which is literally just
paying out profit for no value
all right and this is an important point
that i need to cover which kind of leads
naturally to the next thing is that
in order for a company to grow it has to
have profit in order for it to weather
storms that it does not see that are
going to come in the future
it needs to have profit to be able to
reinvest in
new product lines in legal defense in
whatever could possibly happen
and when you just choose to buy things
for no value which is essentially what
it is when you just
overpay then you put your company in a
bad position so let me explain
so an investor looks at any kind of
asset and
a company the assets of the company are
the humans
right or the or the it's human capital
it's the actual value that you get
from people especially if you're in a
service business right and so
you have the value is what you get
and price is what you pay right and the
goal
i want to be very transparent about this
of the company is to pay as little as
possible
for as the highest amount of value and
that may make people uncomfortable
but the point of all businesses is to
give
to get as much pride they want to have
as big of a discrepancy as possible so
if i'm an investor and i'm buying stocks
i want to buy the most valuable company
that i can for the least amount of money
right it's a price to value discrepancy
right the bigger that discrepancy the
better it is now
if it's the reverse you're paying more
for less value that is a bad deal it
doesn't matter what you're paying
it's a bad deal all right and so the
reason that that first hr director made
such a terrible decision was because she
literally just
chose to take it literally take our good
deals and just say hey
we're gonna make bad deals now and all
of our bad deals we're going to keep as
bad deals
right it just it just it just it just i
it made no sense whatsoever and so
that's that is what we're like that is
the goal here right
and finally
when i was talking to our hr director
about this
she pushed back on this she was um not
sorry not her but like you might have
you might have any character you might
have a man who might push back on this
idea and so i just went
and the two different two different
scenarios came up um that we were
walking through
and one of them is well you know uh you
as the entrepreneur
you know you always value the marketing
the sales
more than the rest of the company uh and
i i could see that there was you know
some being at odds with that right like
i don't know if i agree with that
um and i want to be 100 clear i
do value marketing sales and product
more than operations
here's why not that long ago
there was a period of time where i had
mentors who were like you need to put
operations first right this is part of
scaling you have to delegate blah blah
blah
and so there was a period of time where
i put operations on a pedestal and was
like no guys we need to just do what
operations wants us to do
and to be clear for definition
operations is everything that is
non-core to the value of the company all
right
that is it that is hr that is finance
that's legal uh all of those
comprise operations all right
and to be clear about what that means is
it's everything that must happen
to keep the company running but is not a
core value driver for top lane revenue
or for customers all right and so
marketing
brings revenue in product delivers value
that is being exchanged for money
that's fundamentally what a company does
it's got stuff and it sells it
right and as long as you're delivering
the stuff or you're
or you're um or you're selling the stuff
that is being
delivered those are core value to the
company everything else
absolutely must happen but um in general
they're not the main
value drivers now that being said there
are ways that those other com those
other
components can provide value indirectly
and that's what i'm going to cover in
this because
i think being an hr director or being a
manager in a company and being in one of
those roles if you're clear on that
uh you will be more valuable to your
owner and if you're interviewing for a
position
and you talk the way that i'm telling
you right now to talk to an owner you
will probably get the job
and probably stay there because they
will know that you understand
what you're talking about so the example
she said well um you know i feel like
you care more about
you know sales and marketing and i said
yes i do and here's why um
and by the way when i did that
operational thing and put operations
first
the company started going down um and we
started making less money and it was
painful
and horrible and i had to basically jump
back in and be like i'm so sorry about
that that was not a good idea we are
keeping
the value we provide and marketing and
sales primary
and operations is secondary to that it
is a supporting role
so if sales says hey we need contracts
uh
you know to be changed because this is
the new offer or whatever
then operations has to say all right
we're gonna go figure that out right
and that is the point the point is that
operations should support
and always enable sales marketing and
product all right
so she said well um i feel like
you know you value you know like a star
salesman
more than you value like a frontline uh
customer service
person uh and so she's like you know
there was a there was a decision
that you know this is this has come up
this you know a zillion times over the
years it's like
you know i i think you value these
positions more and i always have to
unequivocally say
i do yes because people people
like and i feel like this is i don't
want to say an employee thing or
it's just like they feel like it's like
a bad word for me to be like no no i do
care about more about marketing sales
and product
period
because they are the major drivers of
value in the company all right
and so um so for example if you had chet
holmes wrote about this in his book
if you have a superstar sales person
this is what i was talking about to the
to the whole company i was like if you
have a superstar sales person
and that person you know is being paid
quote above market right above market
value
there's two ways of seeing market value
there's market value which is like what
is the rest of the market paying for
this right
and then what am i getting in return for
this specific person so for like if you
have an all-star sales person
like you may have gone through 20 sales
people to find an all-star sales person
for your specific company in your
specific product
right because there are some sales
people who who excel
in let's say b2c transactional sales all
right and there's some who who excel
in you know a longer style b2b
consultative sales and there are
some sales people who excel in account
management and kind of upselling and
kind of like the farming and continuing
to grow an account
right those are all sales they're just
different and so
i could find a salesperson right but
that person might not perfectly fit my
company
and i might not yield the same outcome
and so if i have for example somebody
who's selling really well
and sells three you know sells more than
three times
uh you know it would take me two or
three normal quote normal sales people
to replace their
production and this is common in most
companies most people have multiple
sales people
there's one person who you know one or
two people always like lead the
pack disproportionately right and
that uh that person right
if in in in many conversations this is
one of them it's like well
if that person came up to you for
example and said well i want a 20
pay raise or a 10 pay raise she was like
i disagree with that and i was like i
think that's stupid that you disagree
with that
i was like make the economic argument if
we lose that person and then we lose
half of our sales
how can you tell me that was not worth
ten percent more on their base salary
so well i hadn't thought about like that
i was like right you need to think like
an owner
right you gotta think like an owner what
am i losing here right um
and to the same degree the corollary to
that uh
is like well i feel like you don't value
customer service as much like what if we
had an amazing customer service role
this is kind of like the counter example
right like
well i feel i feel like you're willing
to you know pay these people more than
you are willing to pay these people and
it's like
yes i am because they provide more value
and i was like okay i hear where you're
coming from
what if this person does an amazing job
in customer service and i was like i get
it
so let's say this person disappears
tomorrow how much less are we gonna make
so probably not a lot i was like right
and so
if you wanted to you know come to me
with a you know customer service person
and say this person you know saves
x percent of people per month and that
results in this much money
and the aggregate of adding a dollar per
hour
example to this person's role still
doesn't
compare to what everyone else on the
team is saving which would be like what
i would consider market right like if i
just brought someone in
who's average and this person is way
above average let's say this person
saves
you know 25 percent of the whole team
saves is from this one person
uh then i'd be like okay well there's a
number value to that and uh you know we
can
incrementally add a certain amount uh
that would mean it was worth
keeping right uh and
i was like but in this example we're
talking about if this person
stopped and just was gone i was like how
much do you think that the company would
make
less she was like it probably wouldn't
change the revenue and i was like
right and for that reason that is how
market value is established and so for
everyone it's like this is the real
world
all right like i don't i don't know what
the the harvard business review
you know says about making happy
employees and like all this
you know whatever hoodoo um in the real
world
you get you don't get a trophy all right
not everyone's first not everyone makes
the most amount of money
you get paid based on the value that you
provide and a good
owner understands that right and so
when we you know we were having these
discussions um
i think that uh it was it was good for
our whole company to
to understand and see like that's the
point here
like the point is to make a profit the
point is to pay
as little as possible for as much value
as possible
right and assess the value of the
individual based on what they contribute
to the bottom line
right and so you know to to wrap this up
if you were you know for
for for hr in general human resources
it's like well then how do i provide
value you provide
value by one protecting the company at
in
all ways all right and the way that you
do that is
first when people come to you and say
hey i want to hire so-and-so
your first answer should probably be no
give me a reason why your team
is so overworked that they can't just
work more right
show me your hour hour utilization that
you have like
and i'll tell you right now and i've
said it in the past a lot of people
don't work that hard all right and a lot
of people will say
that they are overworked because they
literally do not understand what work
is all the time
i know this for a fact there are some of
you listening to this right now who
spend your entire day not working trying
to work
spend all day getting [ __ ] all done
because you're in your head and you
literally have an inability to focus
that is not a company's fault that is
your
lack of ability in being disciplined and
learning the skills of learning how to
work
like you have to get you just have to
you have to get things done you know and
so many people don't get much done in
their whole day
and then say hey i need help when it's
really like they
aren't actually overworked they actually
just don't know how to work
all right and mind you this is not this
is a lesson that i learned because i was
younger once and i
started working at a law firm as an
intern and
i remember a senior partner jokingly
said to me she was like
you don't even know what work is yet
she's like you haven't even learned how
to work
and i and i was like offended um but
then i saw how hard these people worked
and lawyers worked
you know in in hardcore law firms they
worked their asses off
and i was like huh she's probably
right right and i started observing the
habits of the people work more and how
much
more they got done so anyways um
point is is that people will come and
try and hire for help when there really
isn't it's not necessary and so that
does not protect the company
it also doesn't protect the employees
because if the company's at risk
everyone's at risk right so you have to
put the company first
right um and so that's thinking like an
owner
so that's number one number two
is that you have are active in
recruiting the best talent
all right because everyone knows that
the value of the company is going to be
based on the value of the people the who
not the what right a good who will
figure out the what and so
really good hr is really good
recruitment it's
talent right it's finding the talent
developing the talent
retaining the talent now obviously not
all that's gonna fall under hr right
recruiting absolutely right
uh you know developing is gonna be more
underneath the departments
and retaining is gonna be a function of
really the department heads and then the
compensation
packages right but the thing is is that
i want to be clear here
if you and this is i'm going to wrap
this back in the original story
when you know the hr director the former
hr director did this big
salary analysis and she said hey this is
our big success we're just paying people
more
and we got nothing back in value as a
company right
um i was like why did we do this
and that's the hard question that you
know obviously wasn't able to answer i
was like why did you
did it because she had nothing to do
right but that's actually why she did it
but
i was like what problem were we solving
here
what was the objective of this
the answer there was none right because
the only reason that you would want to
move compensation
is for one of two things either you
cannot attract talent
or you cannot retain talent so what i
mean by that is like
the only reason to really increase
someone's pay if they are
already working for you is because you
value them enough
that replacing them with someone else
who has a comparable skill set would not
the marginal difference would not be
like if if the margin difference is huge
right then you
you'd be incentivized to retain them
right and you as a company
in this hypothetical example have a
problem retaining employees
we at gym launch do not have that
problem we we have
incredibly low attrition we fire people
like crazy
but people don't quit um and
that's because we have a really high
performance culture like people don't
last you know what i mean like it's
uh like sorry low performance don't last
uh it's i i heard this from grant
cardone but i really liked it it's like
gym launch is a dangerous place to work
like if you if you come in and you get
on the train
like you will learn more from me and us
and running a company and learning how
to grow things
uh than ever before but uh you gotta
perform like this is a winner's
environment and if you are a winner you
will love it here
and if you are not a winner you will not
i mean you won't be here very long right
because the thing is is when you come if
you've ever played on a high performance
sports team
your whole life at some point or any
kind of team that was high performing
that was a winning team
usually there's a culture that if
someone is new and comes in
they either assimilate or are rejected
and the stronger that core team is is
like this is how we do it
right we wake up at five we go over our
scripts
we role play we do game day review from
the day before on sales calls blah blah
blah we you know etc
and someone new is like oh man that's
you guys are waking up early like i'm
not really about that life
like like the team will be like dude get
this guy out of here like he's gonna
take the team down
and so having that culture
uh allows you to spit people out quickly
but it also allows you to retain
now this is my point uh earlier which
was
uh why did this hr manager
director make this call right and
obviously it was because she wasn't
thinking
right um but there was no problem that
she was trying to solve
which is i was like this is this was a
hard time for her i can imagine because
it was in front of the entire company
i was like do we have a problem
attracting talent it's like no i was
like okay
so the pay that we are currently
offering is we're having no
issue finding talented people to work
for these positions
at these price points it's like no it's
like okay
do we have a major problem in attrition
are we losing
employees left and right to competitors
who are paying more
offering more or that we got headhunters
picking off our people
she's like no it's like then why did you
just choose to spend 600 000
a year more of bottom line profit
why
in the answer she had none right and so
it's making sure that we understand the
why
we're doing things right the point of
the company
is to buy value at the lowest possible
price that is the point i don't care
what anyone else says that is the point
all right you're going to try and pay
for the value as little as you can
because that discrepancy is where the
profit is right
just being real that's where the profit
is you need to have a discrepancy in
order to have a profit so that the
company can continue to run
right that's what it is
and so anywho uh i share the story at
the beginning because that
is you know one of a zillion
failures you know in lessons that i've
learned along the way in this in this
game
and um you know if you have a star
employee i think a lot of times it is
worth paying them more to keep them
because you get
like everyone knows if you have a star
employee
they're usually worth like three or four
employees five employees in output
right i'm probably worth a lot of
employees and output in terms of top
line revenue this business
so i get disproportionately paid is it
fair
i think yes it is fair i think you
should always be
compensated based on the value they
provide i think that's the ultimate
fairness
i don't think it's like oh he's a human
i'm a human we should get paid the same
thing that doesn't make sense to me
all right so i want to make sure i hit
all my points making employees happy is
not your problem
it is their problem it is their
responsibility now you can equip them
with tools and skills about mindset and
whatnot
but like ultimately the accountability
of who needs to make who happy
you need to make yourself happy a job is
not supposed to make you happy because
there are people who are endlessly happy
in quote terrible jobs and they're
people who have amazing jobs and kill
themselves
so it has nothing to do with you number
one number two
your employees are not your customers
all right your company is always your
customer number one
because the company balances the
priorities of everyone the shareholders
the customers and the employees all
right
i'm a quote middleman uh between the
employees and ownership
that is not true you protect the company
all right
these are false beliefs these are not
true all right um
you know undervaluing uh people who are
not
value pro uh you know top line value
providing right they're not
delivering on on on the value that we're
selling or selling the value right
that's those are fundamentally what a
company does we
sell value and then we deliver on the
promise that's it right
and if you're not in one of those core
things
unless you can make an argument for how
you were directly
uh providing value then you will
probably get paid less
and that's okay and that's okay
right um fundamentally thinking about
all
uh employees as units of value and
ascribing a price to them
right which is what you pay them and
trying to always understand that you're
always going to try and pay as little as
you can for the most amount of value
right that is and that's okay that's
that that's okay
that's the point right the only reason
that you would pay more is if you have
trouble
attracting or retaining people if you're
not having any issues or attracting or
retaining people
then you're paying fine right like you
don't need to change the comp
and so finally um that is what i will
lead you with or end you uh
or leave you with in this role of hr
and my many many lessons along the way
um i hope
you enjoyed this and click subscribe and
all of that good stuff but uh
i have some passion with this because
it's i've made these mistakes so many
times and i've seen these mistakes
made on my behalf and so if you're a
manager if you're an hr director
take this to heart you work for the
company
the company is your only customer
and your responsibility is to protect
the company just like everyone else's
responsibilities to protect the company
and if you can think like that you will
think like an owner and you will move
up in your company if you live in a la
la land
of i'm supposed to just buy bean bags
and have
you know and and keep employees happy um
one you're gonna waste money two you're
not gonna know what actually provides
value in a business
and three if you're in a different
company what what may happen if you
don't have like a candid owner or
whatever who wants to like talk real
with you
um they'll just kind of like put you in
a corner right and then just be like oh
yeah
yeah yeah you bet yeah go do that little
initiative um
but they won't actually see you as
valuable because it means because you
don't get the
game like you don't get it you have to
understand it um
and then people like you you'll get into
the in circle
i'm trying to say this the right way
you've probably
had people in your life where you've got
you've got your friends
right um and you're like she gets it or
he gets it right you talk to your
friends like nah she gets it right she
gets how
this like how we see the world right the
thing is
that most business owners see the world
the same way
and that's why they are the owners of
the business and that's why they started
the business and that is probably how
business has grown
and so it is in your best interest to
align
with the company overall because a good
owner will put the company first
not themselves because ultimately they
the company feeds them the company is
the goose the company is the
is the is the is the beast that feeds
everyone it is the thing that plows the
field it is the mule
that everyone is fed off of and so we
have to keep the mule healthy
and that is by having the discrepancies
and making the hard conversations and
making the hard calls and being real
with you
which is what i'm hopefully trying to do
right now which is that is the point
all right um so anywho uh i hope that
was valuable for you i hope that made
sense hopefully you don't have to
to pay the many lessons uh and failures
that i have and
uh if you have an hr manager or a
manager who you know
hires and argues for compensation things
like that
send this to him i think it's valuable
so anyways lots of love catch you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you